alors chers amis qui nous regardaient de
chez vous chers professionnels du cinéma
qui est dans cette salle alors
professionnelle du cinéma et pas
uniquement d'ailleurs je veux dire il y
a pas seulement des professionnels du
cinéma dans la salle voilà dans les
grands événements on a toujours son
petit quota de picassiette
non je vais pas demander qu'on vous
filme les picassiettes rassurez-vous
enfin
en arrivant dans le hall j'ai croisé le
responsable de l'Office de Tourisme du
Mont-Saint-Michel
le lien avec le cinéma est pas urgent
au huitième range la voix d'ici elle
sait que je la vois
il y a la responsable des ventes de chez
Volvo
vous venez pas Claudine on faisait la
cérémonie quand même
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure quand je suis
arrivé dans le haut je raconte ça
fait une boulette une toute petite
boulette et une dame toute mignonne dans
la file pour entrer alors vous savez on
est là on sait pas quoi faire dans son
manteau dans les mains en piétine et
puis moi gentil je lui dis ah c'est
votre première fois César elle me dit
oui je dis vous êtes de la famille d'un
dénommé cela faire quelque chose
quelqu'un de sa famille qui peut-être
dans quelques instants s'apprête à
recevoir un César là elle me coupe elle
me dit non Jérôme je suis la ministre de
la Culture
la ministre vous avez une notoriété en
devenir voilà non
vous n'êtes pas emmerdé quand vous
faites vos courses quoi
on est pas prêt de voir chanter à la
mi-temps du Super Bowl c'est la couleur
c'est vrai qu'à une époque des charges
au César tout le monde connaissait Jack
Lang ce brushing corbeau noir de Jette
chez L'Oréal au milieu de la salle tout
le monde s'asseyait autour comme des
amis je prennent un feu de bois tu étais
là chauffer les mains
c'est facile à reconnaître tu vois
la soirée se passe bien nous sommes
entre amis même les ministres c'est
maintenant le moment de décerner le
César du meilleur montage